every single thing that you just said is
untrue the Jews were the original Nation
hundreds and hundreds of years before
Islam was even invented basically the
precursor of the United Nations the
League of Nations decided that as a
matter of international treaty
obligation the British will be given
custodianship of Palestine called the
Mandate under which Britain would be
under a binding treaty obligation to
return the Jews to their ancestral
Homeland to recreate it now what was
Palestine at the time well bit of it a
very large chunk of it was was promptly
given away to the Arabs by Winston
Churchill to become trans Jordan which
is now Jordan so what did that leave as
the territory within which Britain had a
binding duty to return the Jews as a
matter of historic right what was that
territory it is what is now Israel what
is called the West Bank and
Gaza